all right it's 1105. i'm gonna try to
start promptly at 1105 each time so
welcome is everybody psyched
i'm psyched
uh this is 913 the human brain i'm nancy
camwisher i'm the prof for this class
unless you were wondering i have a brain
and there it is that's me with some bits
colored in that you will learn about in
this class
okay
um what i'm going to do today is i'm
going to tell you a brief story for
around 10 minutes
and then i'm going to talk about the
why how and what of studying the human
brain why it's a cool thing to do how
you do it and what in particular we're
going to learn about in here
and then we'll do some mechanics and
details of the course and allocation of
grades and all that it's on the syllabus
anyway
cool that's the agenda
all right so let's start with that story
and for this i'm going to sit up here
the story isn't that long but it has a
lot of interesting little weird bits so
i have cue cards to remind myself of all
the bits i want to remember to say
um so uh you can put away your phones
and your computers and you don't need to
take notes this is just a story
it's going to foreshadow a lot of the
themes in the course but it's not stuff
you're going to be tested on okay
so
um this is a true story
and i've changed only a few tiny little
bits
to protect the identity of the people
involved but otherwise it's an
absolutely true story
it's a story about a scary medical
situation that happened to a friend of
mine a few years ago
but at the same time
it's a story about the nature of the
human mind
about the organization of the human
brain
and it's also a story about
the ability or lack thereof
to recover after brain damage
it's also incidentally
a story about
resilience
privilege
expertise and all of those things that
are characteristic of many people in
cambridge society
not so relevant for the course but
all right here goes
so a few years ago a friend of mine
was staying over at my house in
cambridge on route to a conference in a
nearby state
and this guy i'll call him bob
was a close friend of mine i'd known him
for years and years
we had we talked regularly we went on
hiking trips together
we were pretty close so he's on route to
this conference he's staying over at my
house the night before
and he the plan was for him to get up
early the next morning and drive to the
conference so we hung out the night
before and chatted
and the next morning he's sleeping in
the next room over from mine
and early in the morning i hear some
shuffling i think yep okay bob is
packing to leave and thank god i don't
need to get up i'm only dimly awake and
so i'm not paying that much attention
shuffle shuffle shuffle in the
background
and then i hear a crash
and i think what the hell is that
and i get up and i go into the next room
and bob is lying on the floor
not moving
i say bob
and there's no answer
and then i shout bob
and there's no answer
and then i dialed 911.
while we were sitting there waiting for
the ambulance to arrive
bob starts to wake up
and he's very woozy but he's alive and
he's making a little bit of sense
and he can't figure out what's going on
and neither can i
and so we're talking and chatting and
he's making a little more sense
but we still don't know what's happening
so then the ambulance arrives incredibly
fast i feel like three minutes boom
there's three emts
rushing in the front door rushing up to
the room where bob was
and they take all his vitals
and they can't find anything wrong
and so they're really casual i guess
they confront stuff like this all the
time i don't
bob doesn't but they're very calm about
it and they're saying well
you could take him to the hospital or
not
and i was like
i think we need to know what just
happened even though he seems okay we
kind of need to know what this is all
about don't you think they're like yeah
you could take them to the er
and i said well um do we need to waste
ambulance resources or do you think it's
safe if i drive him myself since there's
a hospital not far away they said you
could drive them yourself
so i drive bob to the mount auburn
hospital er which is like less than a
mile from my house
and we do the usual er thing which is
mostly waiting and waiting and waiting
but various docs come by and they take
all these tests and they take all these
history questions and it goes on and on
and
basically they're just not finding
anything
so after about an hour or two of this
they're still doing tests they don't
want to quite let them go yet because
they don't know what happened
everybody's calm about it
i figure okay fine i got work to do
and i tell bob
you know text me throughout the day and
i'll come get you whenever they're ready
to release you
and so um
i go into work
but just before i go to work
a thought flashes through my mind
and i say to the er doc
you know
you should check bob's brain
and the reason that thought flashed
through my mind is that actually i had
been worrying about bob
for a number of years and i hadn't
really it hadn't quite registered
consciously i hadn't was kind of too
horrifying a thought for me to really
allow myself to realize i was worried
about bob's brain but i was worried
about a very particular thing and that
is that bob
had been showing these weird signs that
he
often got lost
and didn't know where he was
and on the one hand this just didn't
make any sense because he was fine in
every other way
but it was really pretty striking so one
time
i was over at bob's house with some
other friends of ours
and the friend asked bob how do we get
how do i drive from your house into
cambridge
and bob said well you go to the end of
the driveway and you turn left
my friend and i looked at each other
like
bob what and bob thinks about it for
minutes yeah end of the driveway turn
left
i just had this like
sinking feeling of dread in the pit of
my stomach
but we sort of made light of it and made
fun of it and it went by and was like no
you turn right and we gave the
directions
another time a friend of mine was
driving with bob in bob's hometown
and
noticed that like bob didn't seem to
know how to get to the grocery store
in his hometown where he'd lived for a
really long time
and you know a trip he'd made hundreds
of times
another time
i was at a conference in germany
and i saw you know these arrays of
posters of people presenting
usually pretty dry scientific things and
out of the corner of my eye i see the
title of a poster and it says
navigational deficits colon and early
sign of alzheimer's and i saw that and i
just thought
and i
just kind of suppressed the thought
and i thought oh my god bob wasn't that
old i know alzheimer's can very rarely
strike early i just i didn't want to
think about it but it was like
rattling around in the back of back of
my consciousness
so there had been these signs
but as i say they didn't make sense
because bob was holding down a very
high-powered job he was writing
beautiful prose he was the life of every
party he was at witty funny
everybody's like favorite life of the
party
so how could that be like it just didn't
make sense that there would be anything
wrong with bob's brain
so i managed for a few years to notice
these signs and ignore them and not pay
any attention
so
the killer thing is
i should have known
better my research for the last 20 years
has been on the very fact that there are
different parts of the brain that do
different things
and one of the corollaries of that
is you can have a problem with one of
those parts
and the other parts can work just fine
and so i if anyone should have realized
yes there's something really wrong with
bob's navigation abilities and the fact
that he's smart and witty and funny and
holding down a high-powered job
doesn't mean there isn't something wrong
with his brain with a part of his brain
but i didn't realize that
but then
you know as i'm leaving the er it kind
of all clicked and i said to the er doc
you better check his brain
i thought bob was out of earshot when i
said that he heard it he's like what i
was like oh never mind
um anyway the er doc with the kind of
confidence that only docs can muster
said nope
not a brain thing this is a hard thing
which wasn't exactly reassuring
but i set aside the brain thought
and i went off to work
so
throughout the day i texted with bob a
few times
things seemed to be fine they'd done
more tests they won't find anything
we just got calmer and calmer about it i
guess sometimes weird stuff happens and
you just move on
but then that night
around seven or eight at night i was
over at a friend's house and the phone
rang
and it was bob
i picked it up and bob says get over
here
they found something in my brain
so i ran out of the house grabbed my
phone and as i'm driving to the mount
auburn er
i called my trusty lab tech an amazing
guy
who keeps track of all kinds of things
much better than i do and i said
i remember that we scanned bob a bunch
of years ago for a regular experiment in
my lab
and i don't remember the date i don't
remember anything about it
but dig around in the files and see if
you can figure it out it might be useful
to have that scan
so by the time i get to the er my lab
tech has already texted me back and said
found the scans i'm putting them in a
drop box for you
so i go into the er and there's bob in
the er doc
and bob says to me
um
do you want to see it
the er doc or the radiologist has
already shown bob the picture of his
brain
and so they take me in there
and i look at it and i gulped there was
a thing the size of a lime smack in the
middle of his brain
pretty terrifying
so
this lime in the middle of bob's brain
was right next to a region
that my lab had studied in great detail
in fact
my lab had discovered that a brain
region right next to where that lime was
located
was specifically involved in navigation
how could i not have put all this
together but i didn't until that moment
and i thought of course of course
there's a thing in his brain right next
to the para hippocampal place area which
i discovered and a nearby related region
called retrospective cortex of course
and how the hell could i not have known
but i didn't know
in that earlier work
it had been nearly 20 years ago i had a
postdoc named russell epstein
and russell was a computer vision guy
and he wanted to understand how we see
by writing code
to duplicate the algorithms that he
thought go on in the human brain when we
understand visual images and that's a
very respectable cool line of work which
we'll learn a little bit about in here
and russell was really a coding guy at
the time we were just starting doing
brain imaging
but russell was like poo-pooing at all
it's like the flash in the pan it's
going to go by it's trashy so you guys
get nice blobs on the brain i'm not
having any of it
and i kept saying russell you need to
get a job
just do one experiment so you can show
in your job talk that you can do brain
imaging it might help you you don't need
to do a lot of it just do one dumb
experiment
russell was interested in how we
recognize scenes not just objects and
faces and words but how do we know where
we are and how do we recognize if the
scene is a
city or a beach or whatever it is
i said okay russell we'll just scan
people looking at pictures of scenes and
looking at other kinds of pictures
and we'll just kind of see if there's
any part of the brain that responds a
lot to scenes
it really was not well thought out this
is not how you should do an experiment
it shouldn't be based on political
calculations lack of theory any of the
above but the fact is that's why we did
that experiment russell needed to be
able to show a brain image in his job
talk so we scan some people looking at
scenes
and the results knocked our socks off we
found a part of the brain that responds
very selectively when you look at images
of scenes not when you look at faces
objects words or pretty much anything
else
and so we'll learn more about that later
in the course we called it the para
hippocampal place area and that launched
a whole major line of work in my lab and
now dozens of other labs around the
world
so backtrack we'd already found that
region and here's this lime in my friend
bob's brain sitting right next to the
peripheral place area
okay
so then
i remembered
let's look at the scans from my lab from
a few years ago in bob's brain
and so i fiddled around and found
managed to download the files
and there it was
you could see that same blob
but in the scans from a few years before
it was much smaller it was the size of a
grape
right
and so that told us a bunch of things
most importantly it told us this thing
is growing really slowly
and that was hugely important because
brain tumors are very bad news
and they usually grow really fast and
the fact that it grew really slowly told
us
that this was not one of the kind of
worst most invasive most horrible ones
it was clearly a problem it was big
but at least it wasn't growing hugely
fast
but how poignant that there it was in my
own damn data and i hadn't seen it in my
friend's brain
well i'm not a radiologist
i'm a basic researcher and i didn't look
and i didn't see it
so indeed the next day the
the docs told us that they thought this
was meningioma not cancer who knew that
you could have tumors that weren't
cancer but you can
and they still need to come out if
they're big enough and that's very
serious but it's not as bad as having
a cancer in your brain
so as we're collecting information the
next day i'm hanging out in the hospital
room and there was an amusing moment
when
one of the residents came by and he's
taking the history and asking all the
basic questions and i said kind of
sheepishly because you don't want to
seem like you know more than the
residents and in fact i didn't really
know more but i just thought i'd provide
a little information i said you know
he's actually
had symptoms for a bunch of years and
there's a there's a region of the brain
nearby that you know that i've actually
studied a little bit and the residence
is like we know who you are
[Laughter]
so much for my you know
trying to stay under the radar
i that afternoon i talked to a
neurosurgeon friend of mine because i
figured okay we need we need advice we
need help
and the um
the neurosurgeon friend said
um
quote it like got branded in my brain
she said it is of paramount importance
that you find the best neurosurgeon it's
the difference between whether bob dies
on the table or goes on to live a normal
life
so this is the privileged part of the
story i'm not that well connected but
i'm a little bit connected and i kind of
dug around and did what i could and
we spent a couple of weeks and we found
the best neurosurgeon
and
the night before the surgery
bob is staying over at my house because
the surgery was in a boston hospital
and i thought you know i've been dancing
around this for years but now like it's
all out in the open we know there's a
problem and i'm going to test him i'm
going to find out what the hell is going
on
this is after all one of the basic uh
forms of data that we collect in my
field that is testing people with
problems in their brain to try to figure
out what things they can do and what
things they can't do it's a way of
figuring out what the basic components
of the mind and brain are it's actually
the oldest most venerable method in our
field and it's still a hugely important
one
so i thought what the hell
so i said okay bob draw me a sketch map
of the floor plan of your
house and so bob takes a few minutes and
he draws this thing
and it was shocking
there weren't even you know the rooms in
a kind of rectilinearly arranged house
they weren't even
aligned there was like a soup of lines
there was no organization from one room
to the next
and bob kind of realized this kind of
isn't right is it but he didn't know how
to fix it and he said he just couldn't
visualize what it looked like to be in
his house and so he couldn't draw the
floor plan
and i thought okay he hasn't been there
in a couple of days i gave him another
piece of paper and i said okay draw the
floor plan of my house where you are
right now
um and so bob took a couple minutes and
delivered a similar mess
he couldn't even imagine the layout of
the room next to him that he'd been at
been in a few minutes before
and then trying to channel my inner
neuropsychologist i thought okay
gave him another piece of paper and i
said okay bob
try a draw a bicycle
why did i choose a bicycle because it's
a multi-part object that has a bunch of
different bits that have a particular
relationship to each other just as the
rooms in a house have a particular
spatial relationship to each other and i
wanted to know is his problem
specifically about places or is it about
any complex multi-part thing that you
have to remember the relationships to
bob is no artist to put it mildly but
his bicycle was clearly recognizable as
a bicycle it had the two wheels in the
right relationship and you know it had
all the basic parts in roughly the same
the right place
i then had him draw a lobster another
multi-part object and also his lobster
was not beautiful but had everything in
the right place
and so that's very telling he had a
specific problem
in i don't know imagining reproducing
remembering it's not totally clear
the arrangements of parts in a room but
not the arrangements of parts and an
object
okay and we'll get back to that more in
a few weeks
okay
so um
what do i want to say here
he said all that
so the next day
bob has an 11 hour surgery
major hardcore extreme neurosurgery
remove a huge piece of bone from the
back of your head
pull apart the hemispheres of the brain
like this go in like multiple inches and
remove a lime like holy crap right
uh said lime was right near the vein of
galen right galen lived what couple
thousand years ago the fact that there's
a vein of galen means it's a big ass
vein the kind of vein that even galen
would have found with you know
dissection two thousand years ago
this lime was all wrapped around and
interleaved with the vein of galen not
good
but because we found the best
neurosurgeon
and because we have extreme privilege
um and all the
all the possible medical resources and
expertise you could possibly hope for
bob sailed through the surgery
and an hour after the surgery i'm
chatting with him and he's making sense
amazing right
so um
and you know two literally two days
later they sent him home
and a few days after that he's back at
work no problem
totally fine
but now we get to the question you're
probably thinking about
what about his navigational abilities
the sad answer is
nothing doing
none of it came back at all
thank god for iphones
if bob lived 30 years ago he wouldn't be
able to function but he goes everywhere
using his iphone gps everywhere
and this fact that he didn't recover his
navigational abilities
is consistent with the whole literature
that we'll consider later in the course
that often
not always but often if you have brain
damage especially to some of these very
specialized circuits that we'll talk
about
you don't recover later
if the damage is early you may well
recover early in life you may well
recover children have much more plastic
brains that can adjust after brain
damage
adults not so good
yeah
so
bob's doing fine
that's my story
any thoughts or questions
yeah
yes
yes
and it's very interesting there are many
of his spatial abilities that are
absolutely intact
and yet the ones related to navigation
are not
yeah
yeah no problem
but he's always looking at his damn
phone to get directions or to listen to
you know the the gps directions system
so driving is no problem it's another
kind of left right the immediate spatial
orientation abilities are absolutely
fine but knowing where am i now and how
would i get there from here is blitzed
other questions yeah
great question
yes he can recognize familiar places
what he can't do is he can say
oh right that's the front of our house
or that's a cafe you know that's such
and such cafe
that's near our house what he can't do
is say which way would you turn from
there to go home
great question great question a little
bit
so he can navigate a little bit with his
gps and because he's learned certain
routes as a series of almost verbal
commands like if you're here turn right
then during your new like that whole
kind of thing
it's not what any of you guys could do
if you guys are driving around in
cambridge or walking around campus
remember when they blocked off this
whole middle of campus
a couple years ago it was so irritating
i would like go there it's like oh god
they've blocked it off i can't get over
to you know lobby seven well you
immediately come up with an alternate
route it's like okay i guess we're gonna
have to do this you come up with an
alternate route this is what you're
never a normal navigation system can do
bob can't do that at all he's like root
blocked no idea get out the phone
right
yes
yes he is and that's very interesting
but that seems to be kind of a different
thing
you could think about all the different
kinds of cues you have for distance
beyond your your kind of literal
navigation skills
a little bit
a couple minutes yes
the next day you know i mean it would it
would be kind of like this thing it's
like you know i sort of vaguely remember
that i was here i turned right so i
better do that again
yeah did you have a question
no not very well and this is a problem
because iphones don't usually yeah
so
new hotels big problem
finding the bathroom down the hall or
the front door in a hotel big problem
yeah
i mean you know these are problems you
can you can come up with workarounds but
it's not life-threatening but it's
extremely inconvenient
yeah
so this is the case um that
those navigational skills that developed
like longer
a long time ago those are stronger so
like he has a harder time developing
like right now he said new hotels are a
problem but if it suffix is like more
familiar
it's a great question and you might
think that the
the kind of navigational maps you laid
down long ago would be intact so is it
just that you can't learn new ones
um
so
it's a it's a great question the answer
is kind of complicated in this case
for roots that he's memorized
there's a whole different system for
knowing a route and really having an
abstract
knowledge of a place that enables you to
devise a new route if something is
blocked on that route right so for
highly overlearned routes he's okay like
he remembers like this you do it's like
a sequence it's like it's like a
memorized motor sequence you do a and
then b and then c and then d
so he's okay with those with roots he
learned long ago but he is not good at
coming up with a new route in a place
that he learned long ago
all right we'll take one last question
no he knows well he knows because like
when he tries to figure out which way to
head he has no idea so he's extremely
aware of it and very articulate
on precisely what happens and so what he
says is like if he's looking at
if he's looking at a place
here's something he says he's looking at
a place he knows where he is because
there's all kinds of other bits of
information that tell you where you are
because you intended to go there and the
relevant things are happening and all
this he knows where he is and it looks
familiar
um
if he tries to imagine what's behind him
he says that he like starts to get it
and it just kind of vaporizes he just
can't hang on to it he can't kind of
construct a stable
mental image of nearby places
so i don't know exactly what that means
but he's very articulate and can report
what happens what he experiences when he
tries to access this kind of information
so what you guys will go on but what i
want to say is what you guys just did
is exactly what we do in my field we try
to take a mental ability
and tease it apart and say is it exactly
this or is it exactly that and you guys
all just did it beautifully right
so a lot of what we do in my field is
kind of this kind of common sense
parsing of mental abilities what is a
particular mental ability
you know how does it relate to some
other one are these things separable can
you lose one and not the other do they
live in different parts of the brain etc
okay all right
so that's the story
i'm going to cash out some of the
particular themes that came out from
this story that will echo through this
course
and the first and most obvious one is
the brain isn't just a big bunch of mush
right
it has structure it has organization
the different bits do different things
okay
importantly
when bob had this big lime in his head
he didn't just get a little bit stupid
no his iq if he'd take an iq test would
be unchanged he lost a very specific
mental ability okay
and that is fascinating
but it's also good news for science
because often when you try to understand
a complicated thing a great way to make
progress is to first figure out what the
parts are and then later try to figure
out how does each individual part work
and how do they work together but if
there's part structure there's at least
a place to start okay
okay
second theme
is that some parts of the brain do
extremely specific things right not all
of them some of them are quite general
and are engaged in lots of different
mental processes but some are remarkably
specific we'll talk a lot about that
third big theme
the organization of the brain
echoes the architecture of the mind
okay um
and i would say the fundamental pieces
of the brain are telling us what are
fundamental parts of the mind
and that's why i'm in this field that's
what i think is cool you know the brain
is just like a bunch of cells like it's
a physical thing who cares about a
physical thing the reason we care about
it is that's where our mind lives and if
we study that physical thing we can
learn something about our minds
and that's pretty cosmic i think
so the point of all of this kind of work
is not to say oh that mental process is
here not there who cares i don't really
care i mean at some point you need to
have a ballpark sense you need to know
to study the things but the interesting
question is not where these things are
in the brain but which mental processes
have their own specialized machinery and
why those
yeah
another important theme how do brains
change right bob didn't recover after
his brain damage in that very particular
mental function that he lost
if if all of that had happened when he
was five years old he probably would
have
right so how do brains change over
normal development
how do they change from learning and
experience
how do they change after injury
and the final theme echoed uh in that
story is there are lots and lots of
different ways to study the brain
right there are the simple behavioral
observations bob can't navigate but he
can do everything else okay that's
really deep and informative low-tech but
really powerful right
um the anatomical brain images that
showed where the line was in bob's brain
right that gives you another kind of
information where what's the physical
structure of the brain
the functional images that we had done
in my lab to discover the para
hippocampal place area
and the studies of what mental abilities
are preserved and which are lost and
people who have alterations of their
brain
okay so those are just a few of the
kinds of methods in our field each of
which tells us about a different kind of
thing about the brain
okay so those are the themes i was
trying to
get at here
so let's move on to
the why how and what of exploring the
brain i'm going to sign the tas to get
me to shut up at um
let's see are we supposed to end it five
minutes before the end of class is that
right is that mit tradition okay
so at uh oh my shockingly soon um 11 45
you're gonna um no
oh great thank you
thank you this is one of the many things
tas are for they pick up the hundreds of
typos and mindos and all of that
excellent i'm thinking how the hell did
i still miss time this thank you heather
okay good we'll go on
okay why should we study the brain
first most obvious reason know thyself
know what this thing is that's operating
in our heads this is who you are right
is your brain
there are lots of very fine and
important
organs in the body
um but the brain is special
right so you know a heart is important
you die without it
um but
it's the brain that's your identity
right so there's a reason that surgeons
do heart transplants that makes sense
something wrong with your heart you need
another heart okay
but why don't they do brain transplants
that wouldn't make sense
right if there's something wrong with my
brain it doesn't make sense to take
someone else's brain and put it in here
because then i'd be that other person it
doesn't make sense because the brain is
who you are
okay so the brain is really special it's
not just another organ
uh that's why a few years ago we had the
decade of the brain
right not the decade of the pancreas or
the liver or the kidney right people
need to study these things they know how
to fix they need to know how to fix them
they're important but they're not as
cosmic as the brain
okay
all right
second reason why we should understand
brains
and that is
to understand the limits of human
knowledge like the more we understand
about the human mind the more we can
like actually evaluate how good our
knowledge is
are there things that we might not be
able to think
possible true scientific theories we
might not be able to understand ever
you can think of studying the mind as a
kind of empirical epistemology a way to
actually know about the knower so we can
figure out how good the knowledge is in
that knower
right so that's another reason
um
a third reason is to advance ai
and so up until a few years ago i used
to give lectures on vision and they
would all start with some version of
this
you guys all have amazing visual
abilities in the back third of your
brain that does vision you can do all
this incredible stuff that no machine
can touch
hats off to you you have an amazing
visual system back here and those guys
in ai it is mostly guys guys gals
whatever those people in ai
um could only dream of coming up with
algorithms as good as the one that's
running in the back of your head
you can't quite start the lectures that
way anymore so if any of you have been
living in a cave and not heard about
deep nets
there's been a massive revolution
and all of a sudden
deep nets are doing things that are
really close to human abilities
particularly in vision
so for example in visual object
recognition
machines were way far behind human
vision until very recently
especially when this paper here
came out was published in 2012
um first author krazefsky
it has now been cited an astonishing 33
000 times actually i made the slide a
couple weeks ago it's probably been
cited 36 000 times by now you can look
it up on google scholar and find out
that is a huge number of citations the
influence of this paper is ginormous
probably half of you have already heard
about this paper raise your hand if
you've heard about this paper oh okay
all right
right major big news okay
so what's so important about this paper
uh well they they trained as probably
most of you know they trained a deep net
on the over a million images in imagenet
a massive computer database of images
and they basically taught it to do
object recognition
and it performs much more accurately
than any previous system and it
approaches human abilities okay so this
is majors as a radical change in the
situation that we were in five years ago
so things have changed radically so just
as an example here's some of the um one
of the figures from that seminal paper
so here is one of the images from
imagenet that that alexnet this trained
network was tested on and the correct
answer according to imagenet is that
that's a mite
and here's what alexnet says its number
one first answer is might and its second
third fourth answers are black widow
cockroach etc right so pretty damn good
the mite is even sticking off the edge
of the frame and it gets it container
ship first choice container ship pretty
good second choice makes sense life boat
not bad
look at that motor scooter i can barely
even see the motor scooter in there but
alexnet
awesome right leopard awesome okay even
when alex net makes a mistake the
mistake is totally understandable
like according to imagenet that is a
picture of a grill and alex net calls it
a convertible i'm siding with alex net
on this one
this
the correct
answer is mushroom and alex net says
agaric i had to look that up it's like a
particular kind of mushroom
this one's pretty funny
imagenet says that's pictures of cherry
there's cherries in the foreground but
alex net says dalmatian i'm siding with
alex ned on this
and you know madagascar cat etc so
pretty amazing and like nothing even
close to this was possible before 2012.
so this is very recent history and it
has totally shaken up the field in lots
of ways
um
and so it's been transformative not just
for computer science but it's also been
transformative for cognitive science and
neuroscience because now we have
algorithms like here's this deep net and
it does this thing
so that's a possible theory of how
humans do it it's a possible
computationally precise theory of what's
going on in here and we didn't used to
have those and now we have those for a
number of domains and that's shaking up
the field there will be a whole lecture
on deep nets and how you can use them to
think about minds and brains toward the
end of the course guest lecture by my
postdoc catherine dobbs
and we'll hear more about that
but let's first step back a second and
say okay do they really perform as well
as humans even on just object
recognition
well
what if we tested it on images not in
imagenet like imagenet's pretty good
test because these things as you can see
are highly variable they have
backgrounds they're complicated they're
real world images
but you know they were photographs taken
by people in a particular way what they
you know with a particular goal
and most of the photographs you take you
throw out they don't end up in imagenet
right imagenet is a weird little
idiosyncratic subset of the kind of
visual experience that we have so
would this really generalize so it so
happens that um boris katz and andre
barbu across the street in csail have
been doing some very interesting studies
this stuff isn't published yet but i got
their permission to tell you about this
cool stuff they're doing and they're
saying hey let's test alex net and other
similar deep nets since then
on a more realistic harder version of
object recognition that's more
characteristic of what humans do and so
they're generating this huge data set of
stimuli that they uh crowd source and so
people workers on mechanical turk go on
there and create images for them and so
they get instructions like you know hold
a hold a object in this particular
location or at this angle or move it
here and like send us the images so they
are getting i think hundreds of
thousands of images
to test this on and they're much more
variable in the location of the object
in the image and its orientation and so
forth so for example you guys have no
problem telling what that thing is but
it's a slightly atypical example
likewise what's the object on the floor
there you can tell what it is but it's
it's slightly atypical example
and so
what boris and andre are finding finding
is that human performance is still
pretty good on these images but the deep
nets are terrible at this stuff okay so
resnet one of the more recent ones um
drops from 71 correct on imagenet to
around 25 percent correct on these
images and the other
similar fancy more recent networks do
similarly badly
so
on the one hand
uh ai the deep nets
are awesome and transformative no
question about it but on the other hand
despite all the hype they're still not
quite like human object recognition
right they're a whole lot closer than
they used to be but they're not really
there okay
and more generally what about harder
problems like image understanding not
just labeling and classification but
understanding what's going on in an
image okay so
you guys have probably seen image
captioning bots
there are lots of these around now this
kind of hit the scene in 2016
when google ai came out with a
captioning algorithm and of course right
around the same time microsoft had a
captioning algorithm and let's see how
they do so this is an example you give
this
algorithm this picture here and it says
that's a dinosaur on top of a surfboard
that's pretty damn good
right like okay wow
let's look more generally how well this
thing works at other examples okay
it looks at this and it says that's a
group of people on the field playing
football it's like wow okay
a snow covered field
pretty good
you should win and
ding ning posing for a picture i don't
know but these things are very good at
face recognition that's probably exactly
those two people right
a car parked in a parking or car yep car
parked in a parking lot pretty good
a large ship in the water pretty good
a clock tower lit up at night
awesome
right
a vintage photo of a pond
well the vintage part i don't know where
the pond is there's a little water in
there i don't know not way off
a group of people that are standing in
the grass near a bridge
not really there's grass
there's a bridge sort of there's people
but not really right
a group of people standing on top of a
boat
definitely not
a building with a cake
what
a person holding a cell phone
not
a group of stuffed animals
i love this one
a necklace made of bananas
wow we've really landed on mars here
a sign sitting on the grass
talk about missing the boat
now look at this picture for a second
just figure out what's going on here
takes a couple seconds everyone got it
there's a lot going on here
okay
so this algorithm says i think it's a
group of people standing next to a man
in a suit and tie
and the algorithm is correct but the
algorithm has profoundly missed the vote
okay
so i'm channeling actually i've stole
these slides from josh tenenbaum but let
me channel him for a moment and say what
his big idea is which i think is really
important
and that is that both humans and deep
nets are very good at pattern
recognition pattern classification this
is a cat or a dog or a car or a
toaster right what they're not good at
what humans are good at but the deep
nets are not is building models to
understand the world
and so when you look at this picture
there are all kinds of things that are
crucial for really understanding at a
deep level what's going on in here
we need to know why some people
what some people here know but the guy
on the scale does not know
namely even if you don't recognize that
that james that's james comey i think it
is
here's obama with his foot on the scale
you need to know
that people find it embarrassing if they
weigh too much
you need to know that he can't see that
obama's doing it you need to know that
they can see it even though he can't and
that's kind of the essence of humor
there's just a whole universe of rich
structural information going in here
that is part of what it means to
understand this picture
and no deep net is even close
to doing that kind of thing
okay
so um bottom line of all this is or let
me just go on more generally
ai systems can't navigate new situations
infer what others believe
use language to communicate
write poetry and music to express how
they feel
or create math
to build bridges devices
and life-saving medicines
that's a quote from our leader jim
dicarlo head of this department
published in wired a year ago and a
beautiful article on the limitations of
deep nets
um but more generally the point is that
yes ai is taking a massive leap now when
we're right in the middle of it and it's
super exciting and it's helpful to
neuroscience and cognitive science
but ai has a lot to learn from us too
right a lot to learn from what's going
on in here and how this thing works
that those ai systems still can't touch
okay so all of that was my third reason
for studying we're still in the why are
we studying the human brain
the fourth reason to study the human
brain is the one most compelling to me
and that is that it is just simply the
greatest intellectual quest of all time
we could fight about cosmology
i'm not going to fight with you about
anything else i don't think there's any
contest it's the greatest intellectual
quest of all time
and that's why i'm in it and that's why
i hope it'll be fun for you
okay that was the why
um
how are we going to study the human
brain
so here's this thing how are we going to
figure out how it works it's kind of
daunting it's not totally obvious
the first thing to realize is that there
are lots of levels of organization in
this thing and hence lots of ways of
studying it
we could look at molecules and their
interactions lots of people in this
building do that
we could look at properties of
individual neurons
we could look at circuits of neurons
interacting with each other we look at
entire brain regions and what their
functions are
we could look at networks of multiple
brain regions interacting with each
other
and so all of those things are possible
but actually what we're going to do in
the course is none of those things in
particular instead we're going to ask a
somewhat different question and that
question is
how does the brain give rise to the mind
okay and to understand that question
we're going to do more at this level and
less at the upper levels okay
um so to answer this question we need to
start with the mind we need to if we're
going to understand how does this thing
produce a mind we need to first figure
out what is a mind what do we know about
minds
okay
and so we need to start with the various
mental functions that minds carry out
things like perception
vision hearing
aspects of cognition like understanding
language thinking about people thinking
about things etc okay
and so for each mental function what
we're going to do in here
is start by trying to understand how it
works in minds as well as we can or like
what it is that we're trying to
understand that minds can do
what is computed and how
and then we're going to look at its
brain basis and try to figure out what
we can figure out about how that mental
function is implemented in a brain
so the first question we'll ask for all
of these domains is is there specialized
machinery to do that thing
and then we'll ask what information is
represented in the relevant parts of the
brain and when is that information
represented
okay
and how
okay so how are we going to answer those
questions
well there's lots and lots of methods in
our field okay
and so the first set of methods if we
want to understand minds the first set
of methods are the basic stuff of
cognitive science psychophysics that
means showing people visual stimuli or
playing them sounds and asking them what
they see or hear nice and low tech but
lots has been learned from those methods
you collect reaction time and accuracy
and it's amazing how much you can learn
from these methods that have been around
for 100 years or more
perceptual illusions are similarly very
informative about how minds work
now let me see an important thing that
arises here
last year was the first time i taught
this course and i would say it went
so-so i'm aiming for it to be much
better this year
uh and one of the ways i'm trying to do
that is to be responsive to the student
evals i got last year which were not
fabulous across the board hurt my
feelings badly but once i got over
myself i decided to just listen to them
and try to fix it and one way to fix it
is to be honest with you today about
what this course is going to cover
so in my valves student 50458
bless them
offered this comment
this class was not sold in the correct
way it should not be called the human
brain because it was basically just a
cognitive science not a brain class i
expected to learn very different
material
so i don't know who the student is i
wish i could apologize to them but i
will say to you
sorry student 50458 sorry to make that
clear
the fundamental the reason the brain is
cool is that it gives rise to the mind
and that means that studying you know
the biological properties of the brain
without considering the mental functions
it implements
it'd be kind of like trying to study the
physical properties of a book without
considering the meaning of its text
so we're going to spend a lot of time
doing cognitive science in here and if
you had a different impression
sorry about that but that's what we're
doing here
okay
all right so how are we going to answer
the lots of cognitive science
um so how are we going to look at the
brain basis
well we're going to look at
neuropsychology patients people like bob
who have damage to the brain and what
functions get preserved and lost we'll
use we'll look at a lot of studies with
functional mri
neurophysiology where you can record
from individual neurons in animal brains
and in rarication cases even in human
brains
under clinical situations where they
need to have electrodes in their brain
anyway for neurosurgery
we'll look at eeg recorded from
electrodes on the scalp
and meg recording from magnetic fields
from squids placed next to the scalp
we'll look at connectivity measures with
a method called diffusion tractography
etc so lots of methods
and so which mental functions will we
cover
well to tell you about that i need to
tell you about the huge progress that
has happened in our field in the last 20
years okay all of this is quite recent
and so let's back up to 1990 here is
approximately what we knew about the
organization of the human brain in 1990.
the black ovals are the bits that are
primary sensory and motor regions that
have been known for a long time even by
1990
and the colored bits are the bits where
we had some idea that face recognition
might go on somewhere in the back end of
the bottom of the right hemisphere
because of people who had damage back
there and lost their face recognition
ability
sometimes preserving their ability to
visually recognize words and faces of
words and scenes and objects only losing
their ability to recognize faces okay
the language regions we had known about
for nearly 200 years from broca and
wernicke and others who had studied
patients with damage in those regions
and noted that they had problems with
language function
and similarly many people had reported
that if you have damage up here in the
parietal lobes you sometimes lose your
ability to direct your attention to
different places in the visual scene so
that was approximately what was known in
1990
and here's what we know now
we now know
thanks largely to functional mri
that for dozens of regions in the brain
and every one of you we have a pretty
good idea of the function of that region
this is major progress right this is a
kind of
rough sketch of the organization of the
human mind and brain that we have now
that we didn't have 20 years ago
and that's awesome
and so that has made possible a lot of
progress
building with other methods and so what
we'll study in this course
is we'll focus on those mental functions
where the brain bases are best
understood
okay and that will include
things like the visual perception of
color shape and motion
visual recognition of faces places
bodies and words
and scenes didn't make it on the slide
oh yes it did perceiving scenes and
navigating
understanding numbers
yes there's a whole lot about the brain
basis of understanding numbers
perceiving speech and perceiving music
understanding language
understanding other people and their
minds
okay so those are the kinds of topics
where there's been a lot of progress
recently in understanding the brain
basis of those mental functions and so
those are the ones we'll focus on
and that means there's going to be a lot
on perception high level vision and high
level audition
um
because you know that's one where a lot
of progress has been made it's also a
lot of the cortex right as i mentioned a
moment ago the whole back third of your
brain does vision construed broadly
right and so some people might say why
she spend all this time in vision well
it's like a big part of what your brain
does we are very visual animals so we'll
spend a lot of time on vision
okay and so for each of these functions
we will ask
to what extent is this mental function
implemented in its own specialized brain
machinery
are there multiple different brain
regions that carry out that function
what does each one do is there a
division of labor between those
different regions
how does that system arise in
development
how does it does it have homologs in
other species are these things uniquely
human or which of them are
and also along the way other side cool
questions that will come up
what if anything is special about the
human brain
how come we are
taking over and largely destroying the
planet
and other species are not right
besides destroying the planet we're
doing some other cool things like
inventing science and engineering and
medicine and architecture and poetry and
literature and all these other music all
these other awesome things that other
species aren't doing how come our brains
are doing that and other species aren't
where does knowledge come from
you guys know all this stuff
how much of that stuff was wired in at
birth and how much of it
did you get from experience
how much can our minds and brains change
over time can we go study a new thing
and get a whole new brain region for
that thing
um
can we change the basic structure just
by training
or after brain damage
can we think without language
right how many of you have wondered
about that question
yeah really basic question anya's
answering it
anya and some others but audio's doing a
lot to answer that question they're
actually empirical answers to these
long-standing deep questions that
everyone wonders about that's pretty
cool um somebody back there asked a
while ago about awareness can we think
perceive understand without awareness
how much can go on like in the basement
of the brain when we don't even know
what's going on down there we'll
consider all of these other cool
questions
okay there's a bunch of things we won't
cover in this course
um
for various reasons that could have been
in here and just aren't there's only so
much time motor control it's really
important to know how you do things like
pick up objects and
plan actions and um
we're just not covering that something
had to go
um
subcortical function all this is a very
corticocentric course most of the course
will deal with the cortex that's where
most of conscious thinking and reasoning
and cognition happens there's a lot of
good stuff down in the basement of the
brain and it's going to get pretty short
shrift okay not for any good reason just
what it is
decision making important field not
getting much coverage in here
importantly circuit level mechanisms uh
explanations of cognition like if you
think that we're going to understand not
only what it means to understand the
meaning of a sentence but that i'm going
to give you a wiring diagram of the
neurons that implement that function
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
nobody has a freaking clue how you could
get a bunch of neurons to understand the
meaning of a sentence okay so that's
exciting that means there's a field for
you guys to waltz into and probably in
your lifetimes people will start to
crack these things right
but you know just to know what we're
headed into rarely for almost no high
level mental functions do we have
anything like
a wiring diagram level understanding of
any perceptual or cognitive function
okay so that's not in the cards for this
course because it doesn't exist in the
field
um
okay for that kind of thing there are
cases where you can make progress you
can understand say fear conditioning in
a mouse like those circuits are being
like cracked wide open by people in this
building people all around the world
with spectacular precision they know the
specific classes of neurons their
connectivity they know every damn thing
about them but it's like you know how
does a mouse learn that this thing is to
be afraid of this thing okay that's
important but you know
for
more complex aspects of cognition in
humans we can't usually have that kind
of circuit level understanding
lots of other things that will get short
shrift memory not for any good reason i
mean there's a lot of coverage of memory
in 900 and 901
and it's just somehow off a blind spot
for understanding i've heard knowing how
to talk interestingly about memory so
i'm not going to give you a boring
lecture on memory instead i'm not going
to give you any lecture on every until i
learn how to talk about it interestingly
reinforcement learning and reward
systems i'm going to try to pull some of
that in but it's not going to be a major
focus even though it's a really
important part of cognition
attention there might be some at the end
okay
um okay how many of you have taken 900
okay looks like a little over a half
okay how many have taken
901
yeah little over half okay good so um uh
if you okay so if you have great good
for you this course is designed for as a
tier two course for people who have
taken 900 or 901 if you haven't you're
probably okay but you might need to do a
little extra work
and so i've already posted online
uh and in the syllabus
information about actually a lecture i
gave a year ago on some of the
background stuff that is no longer
taught in this course people hated it
when i taught them stuff they'd already
encountered before so i'm trying to
minimize that
and so that's a backup for those of you
who haven't taken these courses if
you're worried about this chat with me
afterwards i think it will be okay just
count on doing a little bit of extra
work not much
okay for those of us you have uh who
have taken it um
there's gonna be a little bit of overlap
it's simply impossible to have zero
overlap i mean what does john gabrielle
900 and mark bair and 901 do they survey
the whole broad field and they pick the
coolest stuff out of every little bit
and they teach it to you exactly as they
should but that means that when i come
along and try to say i'm going to do a
more intensive coverage of the coolest
things there's going to be a teeny bit
of overlap but i'll try to not make it
too much okay just because the coolest
stuff is the coolest stuff right
uh okay
[Music]
also the spin and the goals of this
course are quite different from both 900
and 901
you will have to memorize a few things
but not much my real goal in this course
is to have you understand things not
memorize a sea of disjointed facts okay
so a little more on the goals
really what i want you to get out of
this course is to appreciate the big
questions in the field and what is at
stake theoretically in each okay
um i want you to understand the methods
in human cognitive neuroscience what
each one can tell you what it can't how
different combinations of methods can
work synergistically and complementarily
to answer different facets of a question
i do want you to gain some actual
knowledge about some of the domains of
cognition where we've learned a bunch
both at the cognitive level and the
brain level
things like face recognition navigation
language understanding music stuff like
that
and
crucially i want you guys to be able to
read current papers in the field so if
you look in the syllabus the first few
papers are like 20 years old but it's
going to accelerate quickly and you'll
be reading papers i'm trying to choose
mostly papers published in the last year
or two okay i'm trying to take you
straight to the cutting edge of the
field okay yeah
are the people is going to be like the
people straight out of research labs or
are they going to be like the annual
no straight out of research labs you're
going to read the real deal not someone
else's blurry just they just read the
abstracts and put in some stuff in the
review article no you're going to read
the actual paper that's the whole deal
yep
um
okay so those are the goals
good
a few things why no textbook
this field is moving too fast for a
textbook plus i have strong opinions and
i don't like any of the textbooks
um
so any textbook is out of date uh we're
going to be reading hot stuff that's hot
off the press and so there's no that's
not in the textbooks yet and so we're
skipping that
and you're going to go straight to
original research articles so we'll be
occasional review articles where
relevant but mostly part of the agenda
of this course is to teach you to be not
afraid of and able to read current
articles in the field
all right you've all been waiting for
this okay details on the grading pretty
standard midterm 25 of the class of the
grade final 25
it will be cumulative but waited toward
the second half
um there's going to be a lot of reading
and writing assignments
approximately
two papers to read per week
and for usually one of those papers per
week you will have a very short
written assignment in which usually i
ask a few simple questions and maybe one
like paragraph level think question
the
essence of these tasks is not the
written reassignment itself the essence
of the task is to understand the paper
if you've understood the paper as you
read it then you should be able to
answer those questions pretty
straightforwardly
and let me just say that understanding a
scientific paper is not trivial when i
read a scientific paper right in my area
where i have all of the background it
takes me hours
hours
it may be five pages it still takes me
hours
it's just how it is so when i assign a
paper and you say oh it's only three
pages you know i can i could do that in
20 minutes oh no you can't
no you can't
right and that's part of what i want you
learn to learn how to do is how to like
really read and understand a scientific
paper allocate the time it takes to
really get it okay so that's a big part
of the
agenda in this task
okay all the stuff
the assignments and the submission of
the assignments will all happen on
stellar your first written response to a
paper is due february 12 at 6 pm
on stellar but there are other readings
that are assigned before that a note
about the schedule i struggled a lot
trying to both have the assignments
happen when you had already learned
enough in lectures to know how to do it
but have it close enough to the topic at
hand so it didn't seem like no longer
relevant that's hard to do both of those
things so the compromise is all of the
assignments are due at 6 pm the night
before the class in which they're
assigned and so if you see that it's
assigned
you know on the
13th
if it's listed on the lecture for the
13th check carefully it's probably due
the night of the i'm getting this wrong
the 12th the night before and that's so
that we in the tas can look at it figure
out what you understood what you didn't
and how to incorporate and explain
whatever you didn't get in the next
lecture okay
all right um quizzes i haven't done this
before nothing i'm going to try
uh they're going to be about eight of
these they're going to be very brief
they're going to happen at the end of
class in class
and you will do them on your computer or
your iphone using google forms if
anybody doesn't have a computer or an
iphone they can bring to class the days
of those
quizzes let us know after class and
we'll come up with a solution okay
the idea of these is not to fish out an
obscure fact that was in one of the
reading assignments and you know ding
you on it like i'm not interested in
that
the the goal of this is just to keep you
up to date keep you doing the readings
keep you up with the material and if you
basically are understanding what you're
reading and understanding the lecture
material maybe you glance at it briefly
before you should do fine on the quizzes
they're just kind of reality checks
right for us to know what people are
getting and not okay
uh okay first quiz is february 20th
blah blah
there is one longer written assignment
that is not due with the usual schedule
of all the other things it's due near
the end and in that one you will
actually design an experiment in a
particular area and that will be i don't
know yet three to five pages something
like that we'll give you more details on
exactly how you want to organize this
and it will be very specific like state
your exact hypothesis state your exact
experimental design etc and you'll get
practice with those things in advance
all right so those are the grading and
requirements um and this is the
you have this all in the syllabus in
front of you this is the lineup of
topics but very briefly let me try to
give you the arc of the class
um
so this is the introduction next time
we're going to do just a teeny bit of
neuroanatomy there will be a teeny bit
of overlap with 900 and 901 there i'm
going to whip through it in very
superficial form i'm doing that largely
because on the following class we have
an amazing privilege which is that one
of the greatest neuroscientists alive
today and graybill will be doing an
actual brain dissection right here in
this class right in front of you it's
going to be awesome i can't wait it's an
incredible privilege it will be a real
human brain and you guys will be and
will be here with all her apparatus and
you guys will be clustered around and if
it's this many god help us but we'll
figure out how to make it work i may let
me just say if there are listeners in
here i may have to tell listeners they
can't come because very sensitive about
not having too many people so stay tuned
on that i haven't quite decided yet
depends how many people are taking the
class
um but it's gonna be amazing
and i want you to remind you of just
some basics so you're not asking her
like what is the hippocampus okay so i
know you should all know that but we'll
just do bear basics
um okay and then we'll have the
dissection that will be great and also
another thing to say is i mentioned that
the subcortical regions are going to get
short shrift in this class that's true
but a lot of what you see in a
dissection is the subcortical stuff
right
cortex is great but it kind of all looks
the same you kind of can't say oh that's
this region that's the other reason why
you can but it doesn't look any
different from any other region right
so um so that's where the subcortical
stuff will happen okay
uh so then i'm going to do a couple of
lectures that focus on
high level vision
perceiving motion and color and shape
and faces and scenes and bodies and
stuff like that
and we will use those both to teach you
that content and also to teach you the
you know
vast array of methods in this field okay
um we will then um have a lecture on
um the kind of debates about the
organization of visual cortex in humans
i have a particular view i'm i'm very
fond of views that some patches of
cortex are very very functionally
specific
not everyone believes that so i have
signed readings of people who have
different views we will consider that i
will try to expose you to the alternate
views
and tell you why i'm teaching why i
still believe mine but why other smart
people believe different things right
okay
we will then move up the system from
perception and we will spend two
meetings talking about scene perception
and navigation you got a hint about what
an interesting area this is from the
story of bob we'll consider more what
we've learned from
studies of patients with brain damage
from functional mirai from physiology
and animals from cognitive science from
the whole glorious menagerie of methods
to understand navigation it's an it's a
really fascinating area
but in the two lectures after that we'll
consider development how do you wire up
a brain how much is present at birth
what is specified in the genes what is
learned
and a lot of that will focus on
the navigation system and the face
system simply because that's where
there's a lot known right we'll consider
some other things but those are two
areas where there's
super exciting work from just the last
three or four years and so that's what
we'll focus on there
um i'm then going to do a lecture on um
brains in blind people how are they
different how are they the same what
does that tell us
and then you have the midterm
then we're going to move on and consider
number how do you like instantly know
that that's three fingers and that's two
without having to do anything all that
complicated
and if i had 25 fingers and held them up
you would immediately get a sense that
it was about 25 you might not know if it
was
22 or 28 but you would know it was about
25
and there are particular brain regions
that compute that for you and we will
consider all of that and there's a
very rich array of information from
studies of infant cognition from animal
behavior from brain imaging from brain
damage from single unit physiology
and from computation all of which inform
our understanding of number those are my
favorite lectures so we can take one
domain of cognition and inform it with
like all of the methods and numbers a
really great example
uh then we'll talk a little bit about
well one of my tas said call it
neuroeconomics it will sound good but
actually what i'm going to try to do is
sort of neuroeconomics but it will be
about
pleasure and pain and reward and how we
think about those things
okay
and then that's down to april 3rd
just as a side note
all of these things are things that are
pretty similar between humans and at
least primates and some of them are
shared with rodents okay
and most of the things after that are
things that are really uniquely human
okay so we'll be really moving away with
less available animal literature to
inform the stuff we're looking at
because animals can't do these things
and so necessarily far from the details
of individual neurons and circuits but
there's still lots cool that can be said
about how you understand speech
how you appreciate music
there will be a guest lecture just for
fun on brain machine interface
by michael cohen who's working in my lab
now and who has a great lecture on this
topic
and then we'll spend a couple lectures
on uh language how you understand and
produce language and what the relevant
brain regions are
what we know about it from cognition and
lots of other methods
and what the relationship is between
language and thought
then we'll think about um how we think
about other people this is called theory
of mind how i can
look out at this lecture and try to
evaluate from your facial expression are
they bored sleepy overworked fascinated
excited all of this kind of stuff that
all of us do moment to moment in any
conversation and that you know yes
lectures are doing all the time
even if i know that you guys have too
much work and that's why you're sleepy
and i shouldn't take it personally
i'm still noticing anyway
then we'll go on and consider brain
networks right so of course brain
function doesn't happen in just a single
region even if we spend a lot of time
studying individual regions
there's considerable work trying to
figure out which sets of regions work
together and how could we discover that
and what are those broader networks of
brain regions
um and then on may 6 you will have
turned in your
longer written assignment designing your
own experiment and then in mace on may 6
we will work together in groups to
refine those experiments and really hash
out the details so you actually know how
to design an experiment
and then we will have this guest lecture
from my postdoc katharina dobbs on deep
nets and what they can tell us about
cognition and brains
and then we'll talk about attention
awareness
and then i'm not totally sure what we're
gonna do in the last class but what i'm
voting for is that the amazing tas each
give a short talk on the cool stuff
they're doing but that's under
discussion
okay that's the arc of the class
questions
all clear
great well if i have five more minutes
maybe i'll do one other little thing let
me try this
um
you asked i'm gonna try to learn
everybody's names but i'm not doing that
yet because some of you might not show
up and i will have wasted a whole piece
of my brain encoding it just kidding
um uh but um anyway remember that you
asked like you're gonna read current
papers yes it is and you're right it's
it's daunting but let me just say a
little bit about how to read papers
this is not a stats course and we
haven't pre-requisite prerequisite stats
neither is is it a course on
the physics of mri
so there will be parts of every mri
paper that have a lot of gobbledygook we
scanned with this scanning procedure
right
you know we use this kind of scanner and
this kind of blah blah blah lots of
gobbledygook you guys don't need to
worry about that
about the stats it's kind of a judgment
call everyone in here should have an
idea of what a p level means
and i hope a sense of what a t-test is
and an anova if you don't i should
probably tell you that offline because
that's you know pretty basic but what a
correlation is beyond that um just use
your intuitions about those things and
we and this is not a course about
understanding the details of the stats
in each experiment there just isn't room
to cover all that in the substance of
the studies as well
so when you read a paper for example
here's a paper
a very old paper you come across this
and it's like okay here are all these
words like how you know it goes on for
20 pages and like how do you even dig in
the way to dig in
is to start by saying what question is
being asked in this paper
if the paper is well written you'll be
able to find that
in the abstract
blah blah blah to study the effect of
face inversion on the human fusiform
face area okay we'll talk about that
more later but if you fish through the
abstract you should be able to find what
questions being asked and it's the first
thing you should figure out about a
paper
okay
you don't necessarily read a paper you
know start to be beginning through the
end i think it's better to start with
this list of questions in your head and
look for the answers to those questions
right
second question what did they find
if the abstract is well written you can
find that in the abstract as well
signal intensity from the fusiform face
area was reduced when grayscale faces
were presented upside down
okay kind of boring but there it is
that's the finding of this paper
okay
um what is the interpretation like in
other words who cares like why who you
know who cares about this okay
if you look in here in the abstract ffa
response to faces per se
rather than to the low level features
present in faces okay we'll talk more
about what that means you guys have an
assignment about that probably several
assignments about that kind of question
okay
next question you want to ask yourself
is what is the design
of this experiment
often for this you have to go beyond the
abstract and i should say for even these
quite these earlier questions sometimes
you won't find them in the abstract that
just means the abstract is not well
written
but that exists
okay to get the design like what exactly
did they do usually you have to fit and
you know what exactly was done
and how were the data analyzed you need
to fish farther you need to fish around
other parts of the paper
and of course all of those questions
okay so i just said okay what question
and we just i circled this part but
there are many levels to what question
so you can get more on you know why why
is that inverted
question important you look through
usually in the introduction to the paper
does the ffa respond to faces per se or
to a confounding visual feature which
tends to be present in faces
second is it true that inverted faces
cannot engage phase specific mechanisms
blah blah blah so that gives you a
little more background on what the
question is right there are different
levels and depths okay
so these are all things you want to be
looking for when you read a paper
what exactly was done we measured mri
responses in the ffa to upright inverted
phases right i don't expect you to
understand all this these are just
giving you schematically how you proceed
when you're reading a paper okay
more on the interpretation or who cares
right this result would show that phase
specific mechanisms are engaged only or
predominantly by upright faces blah blah
blah right you can fish through for
those things
point is to have those questions in your
head when you read a paper okay
it's much it's much more easy and
engaging to read something if you have
an agenda when you read it and so your
agenda in reading scientific papers is
to answer those questions for yourself
right uh
more stuff what was the design and logic
often that's deep in the methods you
have to fish around and find it there
will be some set of conditions and
designs we'll talk more about all this
kind of stuff
what exactly was done you know blah blah
more details
um
okay
um and this is my example of the kind of
gobbledygook that you can ignore okay
uh so subjects were scanned on a one and
a half t scanner and they're all these
like this here's the example of god said
gobbledygook
you can ignore this in this class right
every method will have different kinds
of gobbledygook this is mri gobbledygook
you can ignore it okay
uh i'm it matters a lot but not here
okay
what else how are the data analyzed if
you look in the
you know sometimes there's a data
analysis section or a results section or
a method section that will tell you you
can find that figure it out okay
what was the finding here's more on the
finding again you just fish through for
these things
um so the point is just
when you're reading a paper you don't
it's not necessarily
what i do is i read the title i read the
abstract
and then i start answering those
questions for myself and sometimes at
that point i'm skipping to figures i'm
skipping to methods
any of that is fine okay
so don't feel like you need to
understand each word especially deep in
the methods i don't know was that
helpful at all
we'll try it and you guys will give me
feedback and
uh if it works great and if not we'll
we'll do more on how to read papers
all right it's 12 25.
see you on monday
you